lange zeit dachte man dass menschen im
wachkoma nicht wahrnehmen was um sie
herum passiert der neurowissenschaftler
eiligen hat aber nachgewiesen das
wachkoma patienten und patientinnen eben
doch bewusstsein besitzen können was die
betroffenen leben also in einer äußerst
rätselhaft und medizinisch kaum
verstanden grauzone zwischen leben und
tod und in 15 jahren will man mit ihnen
fließend kommunizieren klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
der 19-jährige kanadier juan fiel im
jahr 2013 ins wachkoma der grund drogen
die sein gehirn geschädigt hatten das
wachkoma ist heute noch immer
weitestgehend von der medizin
unverstanden nimmt solch ein patient
etwas von seiner umgebung war
und wenn ja wie viel und was genau
feststeht in deutschland sind es pro
jahr bis zu 40.000 menschen die ins koma
fallen
ausgelöst durch schwere hirnverletzungen
diese stammen meist von einem unfall
oder einem schlaganfall und das fatale
bis zu 5000 menschen befinden sich dann
ein halbes jahr oder länger zum teil
sogar bis zu ihrem tod im wachkoma
die augen der patienten und patientinnen
sind dauerhaft geschlossen
teilweise müssen die betroffenen
künstlich ernährt und beatmet werden
dem 19 jährigen juan jedenfalls ging es
2013 miserabel auf der skala bekam er
den niedrigsten aller möglichen werte
und der sagt aus dass er sich quasi ganz
knapp über dem tod befindet juan wurde
damals von dem britischen
neurowissenschaftler junioren und seinem
team behandelt dieses canton sein gehirn
währenddessen der patient einen
gruseligen alfred hitchcock film ansah
doch das ergebnis war nicht eindeutig
was seine mutter aber nicht davon
abhielt alle möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen
sie gab nicht auf das gehirn ihres
sohnes zu stimulieren unter anderem mit
kaffeebohnen die sie ihm unter die nase
hielt heute steht fest juan hat all das
mitbekommen
das behauptet er zumindest selbst denn
er ist wieder fit und geht sogar aufs
college doch das team an
neurowissenschaftlern sagt selbst dass
der verein sehr außergewöhnlich und
erstaunlich sei ihre erklärung für
seinen heilungsprozess der physische
schäden am gehirn war nicht besonders
groß und so konnten
hirnstimulation besonders gut beim
anschlagen doch das konnte er im zustand
des wachkomas so natürlich nicht
mitteilen
heute sagt dass er die ganze zeit wusste
dass er es zurück ins echte leben
schaffen würde auch andere wachkoma
patienten und patientinnen von alien
verfügen über ein bestimmtes maß an
bewusstsein gemessen werden kann dies in
verschiedenen tests das team des briten
beispielsweise bittet die patienten und
patientinnen darum in ihrer vorstellung
tennis zu spielen
die hirnaktivität der betroffenen wird
dann mit bildgebenden verfahren
überprüft beispielsweise mit hilfe der
magnetresonanztomographie zeigen die
messinstrumente dann eine deutlich
messbare aktivität im pre motorischen
kortex kann man auf vorhandenes
bewusstsein schließen und das sind nicht
wenige derjenigen wachkoma patienten und
patientinnen die nach außen hin keine
reaktion zeigen 17 prozent nämlich die
demnach dennoch über ein bewusstsein
verfügen so die forschung der briten
andere aktuelle studien bestätigen diese
zahl bzw übertreffen diese noch wie etwa
eine aktuelle studie die sogar von 20
prozent ausgeht ein fünftel der
wachkomapatienten und patienten wäre
demnach bei bewusstsein
diese ergebnisse machen um so deutlicher
wie wichtig es ist dass sich intensiv um
wachkoma patienten und patientinnen
gekümmert werden muss psychologische
studien bestätigen dass vernachlässigung
und soziale isolation haben demnach
schlimme konsequenzen für das
menschliche gehirn ebenso zeigen diese
untersuchung aber auch dass selbst
patienten und patientinnen im wachkoma
durchaus noch hoffnung haben können und
das ist extrem wichtig bei der
erstellung von patientenverfügung dazu
und was ist wenn patienten entgegen
ihrem zuvor dokumentierten willen ihre
meinung ändern was etwa login patienten
betrifft mit denen ja zum teil
kommuniziert werden kann so ist eines
klar sie wollen fast nie sterben
ich glaube deshalb die menschen sollten
vor dem verfassen einer
patientenverfügung viel gründlicher über
diesen wachkoma zustand nachdenken sie
sollten darauf gefasst sein dass sie
eventuell anders darüber denken würden
wenn sie sich in solch einer situation
befinden
der neurowissenschaftler ist durchaus
optimistisch und geht davon aus dass es
schon sehr bald technische möglichkeiten
geben wird um eine kommunikation mit
wachkoma patienten und patientinnen
zu ermöglichen in spätestens 15 jahren
rechnen damit dass wir in der lage sein
werden uns fließend mit wachkoma
patienten und patientinnen unterhalten
zu können
dabei schließt er die funktionelle
magnetresonanztomographie als
technologie übrigens aus und sieht
dagegen in der sogenannten nahe infrarot
spektroskopie eine große chance ein
bildgebendes verfahren bei der
bestimmung der hirnaktivität das schon
seit rund 30 jahren in der medizin
genutzt wird konkret geht es dabei um
den sauerstoffgehalt im blut von dem man
auf die hirnaktivität rückschließen kann
denn änderungen der hirnaktivität sind
mit änderungen des sauerstoff und
energiebedarfs gekoppelt dieses
verfahren hat laut oben bereits bei
einem patienten funktioniert hierbei
wollte das medizinerteam herausfinden ob
der betroffene schmerzen hat und mehr
medizin benötigt doch handelte sich bei
diesem konkreten fall nicht um einen
wachkomapatienten ohne es jedoch hoch
motiviert das auch in solchen fällen
demnächst erfolgreich anzuwenden vielen
dank an technology review in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser
ziemlich coolen zeitschrift ist dieses
video entstanden und exklusiv für klick
zum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein
geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine
ausgabe gratis wenn er auf diesen link
geklickt das lohnt sich wirklich ich
kann die zeitschrift absolut nur
empfehlen und uns natürlich auch wozzeck
folgen der linke ist jetzt hier in der
video beschreibung und am besten auch
mein schwesterkanal klicks um social
media abonnieren das geht hier da gibt
es das neueste aus der social media welt
einfach draufklicken aber nicht
natürlich nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch drauf klicken
so fühlt es sich an zu sterben bis dann
bleibt dran